hello everyone my name is Stella Rona
gruvachich and I'm going to tell you in
60 seconds why diversity and inclusion
matter let us imagine imagine a greater
mainstreaming of equality diversity and
inclusion in the EU and its external
action imagine that we fully Embrace
diversity everyone can be themselves
everyone feels respected and valued
imagine a world where nobody faces
threats or violence harassment or worse
because of their sexual orientation or
gender identity a world where everyone
can love who they want to love where
everyone fully enjoys their human rights
without discrimination based on any
ground where Civil Society has space to
promote and enjoy these Universal values
this is why diversity and inclusion
matter everywhere making this a reality
starts with ourselves by practicing what
we preach and leaving no one behind it's
not unimaginable
did I make it